هادي العامري باطلاق حوار وطني
ينهي الازمة السياسية في البلاد.
تدخل في حرب الاغتيالات. فمن
ستكون الشخصية القادمة? وبماذا
في تغيير النظام السياسي؟ انقرة
تمد يدها بنظام الاسد وروسيا
الجيل الثاني. ضياع لمفتاح الحل
السياسي في العراق. اتهامات من
المتوقفة عن العمل بالاضافة الى
بناء مفاعلات نووية جديدة من
فهل سيتجه العراقيون للحوار
لانقاذ بلدهم؟ ام ان الصدر سينجح
الفساد؟ والقضاء سيلجأ لكشف
ملفات فساد بعض الشخصيات وذلك
الاسرائيلي بحملة تأهب عسكري على
الحدود. قال رئيس الوزراء
بالتزامن مع مطالب رئيس الوزراء
مصطفى الكاظمي ورئيس تحالف الفتح
على حقوقه كاملة واكد التزامه في
الوقت نفسه بضبط ليرد الكيان
وخمسين وثيقة مطلع العام الجاري.
فهل ستكون هذه الوثائق القشة
التيار الصدري في العراق للسلطة
القضائية بالضلوع في حماية
التي ستقسم ظهر البعير حزب الله
يهدد بالتصعيد اذا لم يحصل لبنان
ومن ميادين الحرب ودخانها الى
طاولة المفاوضات النووية حيث
النووي الايراني. الرد من
واشنطن. وبلسان المتحدث باسم
مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي جون
كيربي قائلا نتفهم مخاوف اسرائيل
عناصر امريكية عشر من اغسطس
والتي استهدفت قاعدة التنف
الاربع والعشرين ساعة القادمة
يدخل الكيان الاسرائيلي في الخط.
والتطورات. حذر ماكرون الفرنسيين
والاوروبيين من صعوبة الايام
لكن واشنطن تريد عودة ايران
للاتفاق النووي. الاحداث
للبضائع والموارد وراحة البال
الاكيدة. نيويورك تايمز ترامب
القادمة مؤكدا ان العالم شهد
نهاية المسلمات والوفرة اليسيرة
في الاتفاقية ولن تلتزم بها
وستستخدم كل قوتها لمنع البرنامج
نقلت واشنطن بوست عن مسؤولين
امريكيين قولهم ان رد الولايات
جماعات تابعة للحرس الثوري
الايراني. واشار الى ان تلك
المتحدة بخصوص مسودة الاتفاق
النووي مع ايران سيكون خلال
على الاتفاقية. معللا ذلك بانه
سيمنح ايران مائتين وخمسين مليار
دولار لاستخدامها من اجل
الارهاب. وان اسرائيل ليست طرفا
هجمات مثل تلك التي شنتها
الجماعات المدعومة من ايران على
الامريكية في سوريا بسلسلة هجمات
بطائرات مسيرة حسب تعبير البيان.
ليصرح نفديت مطالبا الادارة
الامريكية بالامتناع عن التوقيع
استهدفت مواقع عسكرية ومنشآت
البنية التحتية التي تستخدمها
الضربات تهدف الى الدفاع عن
القوات الامريكية وحمايتها من
وبقية الدول العربية كما ندد
لافروف بالقصف الاسرائيلي الذي
طال مطار دمشق وميناء طرطوس.
برأيكم هل روسيا هي من تمتلك
جوية دقيقة في سوريا. وفي بيان
للقيادة الامريكية فان الضربات
الخارجية الروسي لافروف قائلا
اردوجان بحث في موسكو مسألة
الياباني اليابان ستعيد تشغيل
مزيد من المحطات النووية
مع استئناف التنسيق الاستخباري
في التاسع عشر من الشهر نفسه.
واضاف ان موسكو مستعدة للمساهمة
في تحسين العلاقات بين سوريا
مفتاح حل الازمة السورية? ايران
تحت القصف. بتوجيه من شنت غارات
ها هو ينفض الغبار من على الملف
السوري. فقد اعلن وزير الخارجية
خرج اردوجان ليعلن عن تصريحات لم
يستبعد فيها الحوار مع دمشق رغم
السياسية ومحاولة كسب الود في
افريقيا اعلنت الصين الغاء ثلاثة
بحث فيها سبل تقديم الدعم مصالحة
بين الحكومة السورية والمعارضة
لقائه مع الاسد. وحذر بروف من شن
اي عمليات عسكرية جديدة في سوريا
بعشرة مليارات دولار وذلك من
ارصدتها في صندوق النقد الدولي
تحذر تركيا. حفيد العثمانيين
يجيد المراوغة السياسية. ها هو
دولار لمشاريع انتاج الطاقة
ومنها الكهرباء تبدع الصين في
احتفظ بنحو ثلاثمائة وثيقة سرية
في منزله ببلوريدا فيما سلم مائة
الازمة الاوكرانية بل ولم يكتف
بذلك فقد فتح بوابته الخلفية كي
التركي في بداية اغسطس الجاري
اجراءه محادثة مع نظيره السوري
الخيال العلمي. وهذا التصريح قد
يمهد لانتاج فيلم جديد من افلام
العراقي. كما قدمت الصين تمويلا
بقيمة عشرة مليارات ونصف المليار
يهرب هوامير الاقتصاد الروسي من
مقصلة العقوبات الامريكية. والان
اليوم يرقص على اوس الثعابين.
فهو يمسك العصا من منتصفها في
الفيلم. يا له من تصريح ساخر
فماريا زاخاروفا هي النسخة
هذا ما ستكشفه الايام القادمة
بالمزيد من السخاء. كشفت دراسات
وعشرين قرضا دون فوائد قدمتها
لسبع عشرة دولة افريقية وتقدر
امريكية جديدة ان الصين تستحوذ
على نسبة كبيرة من الاستثمارات
لعبتها المفضلة وهي الاقتصاد.
فماذا عن كرم واشنطن? وروسيا
الرسمية للخالة فرنسا فرع روسيا
فتصريحاتها نارية وردودها لاذعة.
الى دول القارة. ما هذا الكرم
الحاتمي وما هو الهدف يا ترى؟
اوستن باورز الخيالية ولا نستبعد
ان تكون ليزترانس هي بطلة
في العراق ما يثير الغرب حيث ان
الصين اشترت نحو نصف انتاج النفط
للقيام به. ليأتي هنا الرد
الروسي وعلى لسان ماريا
زاخاروفا. وزيرة الخارجية
البريطانية تكثر من مشاهدة افلام
الوزيرة صرحت في تصريحات صحفية
ان هذا واجب مهم وهي مستعدة
لعبة الصين المفضلة. من وسط
الزحام الاقتصادي والتملقات
لاستخدام السلاح النووي في حالة
الضرورة اذا اصبح رئيسة للوزراء.
مكونات لاسلحة بيولوجية على حد
قوله. واوضح شويجو ان العملية
تمسكه بعمليات جيشه العسكري في
الشمال السوري ليتدخل هنا وزير
يضاعف عدد الخسائر البشرية بما
يطيل امد الصراع. ويجب عليهم الا
العسكرية في اوكرانيا تسير وفق
المخطط لها. وهنا بريطانيا وفي
تصريح غير مسبوق لوزيرة الخارجية
البريطانية تقول انها مستعدة
امدادات الاسلحة الى اوكرانيا من
قبل الولايات المتحدة وحلفائها
المدن الاوكرانية لتعلن هنا
الاستخبارات الروسية عن القبض
الروسي المتشدد الكسندر دوجين
والمقرب من بوتين. اليوم تم
اوكرانيا ليأتي الرد من وزير
الدفاع الروسي سيرجي شويجو.
الامين العام لحلف شمال الاطلسي
ينس تولتنبرغ ان الحلف سيتم في
دعم اوكرانيا ماديا وعسكريا.
ودعا موسكو الى سحب قواتها من
مهمة لروسيا. نعم وبنفس طريقة
مقتل دايا دوجين ابنة المفكر
الحدود اللبنانية. فما هو السبب?
حرب الظلام. بعد ان استهدفوا
على جاسوسين اوكرانيين. ومن حرب
الظلام الى حلف الناتو حيث اكد
جديد لتثير الشكوك حول المواطنين
الاوكرانيين الذين تم تجنيسهم من
فهل من منقذ وجيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي يتأهب عسكريا على
للقصف الامريكي. اليابان تطلب
الضوء الاخضر من واشنطن لبناء
اصابع الاتهام تشير الى اوكرانيا
فهل هذا تكتيك عسكري اوكراني
مفاعلات نووية فبماذا يفكر
اليابانيون والعراق يموت سريريا
بسخرية. الصين تتسبب بفاجعة
اقتصادية لامريكا وروسيا تحذر
اغتيال رئيس الادارة العسكرية
والمدنية بانفجار لغم مزروع
صدمة بعد اغتيال شخصية جديدة
وبارزة في روسيا فمن هي الجهة
سيرد بوتين?
بعد محاولة اغتيال عقل بوتين
الكسندر دوجين. بوتين في حالة
يحلموا ان الحرب الاستنزافية
ستنهك روسيا. واكد شويجو ان مول
اكثر من ثلاثين مختبرا بيولوجيا
في اوكرانيا كانت تطور فيه
بوتين الكسندر دوجين. وقبل ان
يتماثل جرح بوتين للشفاء ويهدأ
غضبه. كشفت اليوم وسائل اعلام
روسية رسمية عن اغتيال شخصية
تركيا من تصادم عسكري. وبتوجيه
من جو بايدن هذه الدولة تتعرض
المنفذة؟ بريطانيا تهدد روسيا
بسلاحها النووي وموسكو ترد